[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JUSTIN: OK.
So it's a pleasure to
see all of you guys.
I'm Justin.
I'm your third
instructor for 6.006.
This is my first time
with this course.
Although, of course,
this is material that we
all know and love in the
computer science department.
I'll admit, I find the
prospect of teaching
sorting to 400 people
all at once is mildly,
low key terrifying.
But we're going
to give it a shot.
And hopefully, that will subside
as the lecture goes on today,
all right?
So we're going to pick up where
we left off in our last lecture
and continue on
with a similar theme
that we're going to see
throughout our algorithms class
here in 6.006.
I think Jason and
colleagues have
done a really great job
of organizing this class
around some interesting themes.
And so I thought I'd start
with just a tiny bit of review
of some key vocabulary words.
Incidentally, typically, I
teach the intro graphics class,
the geometry course.
And last year, I
got feedback that
said I have serial
killer handwriting.
I'm not 100% sure
what that means.
But we're going to use
the slides a tiny bit more
than normal, just to make
sure you guys can read.
And when I'm writing
on the board,
at any point, if you
can't tell what I wrote,
it's definitely me and not you.
So just let me know.
But in any event, in 6.006, all
the way back in our lecture 1--
I know that was
a long time ago--
we introduced two big keywords
that are closely related,
but not precisely the same.
Hopefully, I've
gotten this right.
But roughly,
there's a theme here
which is that there's an object
called an interface, which is
just a program specification.
It's just telling
us that there's
a collection of operations
that we want to implement.
So for example, a set, as
we're going to see today,
is like a big pile of things.
And behind the scenes,
how I choose to implement
it can affect the runtime
and how efficient my set is.
But the actual way
that I interact with it
is the same, whether I use an
unsorted array, a sorted array,
what have you.
On the other hand, what
happens behind the scenes
is something called
a data structure,
which is a way to
actually, in some sense,
implement an interface.
So this is the object
that on my computer
is actually storing
the information
and implementing the
set of operations
that I've laid out
in my interface.
And so this sort of
distinction, I think,
is a critical theme
in this course
because, for instance, in
the first couple weeks,
we're going to talk about many
different ways to implement
a set.
I'm going to see that
there's a bunch of tradeoffs.
Some of them are really
fast for certain operations
and slow for others.
And so essentially, we have
two different decisions
to make when we
choose an algorithm.
One is making sure
that the interface
is correct for the problem
that we're concerned with.
And the other is choosing an
appropriate data structure
whose efficiency, and memory
usage, and so on aligns
with the priorities that we
have for the application we
have in mind.
So hopefully, this high
level theme makes sense.
And really, spiritually, I
think this is the main message
to get out of this course in
the first couple of weeks,
even though these
O's, and thetas,
and so on are easy to lose
the forest through the trees.
In any event, today,
in our lecture,
we're concerned with one
particular interface,
which is called a set.
A set is exactly
what it sounds like.
It's a big pile of things.
And so a set interface
is like an object
that just you can keep
adding things to it.
And then querying inside of
my set, is this object here?
Can I find it?
And then maybe I
associate with my objects
in my set different information.
So for example,
maybe I have a set
which represents all the
students in our classroom
today.
Yeah, and all of you guys are
associated with your student
ID, which I believe
at MIT is a number,
which has less than sign,
which is convenient.
So we can sort all of you guys.
And that might be the
key that's associated
to every object in the room.
And so when I'm
searching for students,
maybe I enter in
the student number.
And then I want to ask
my set, does this number
exist in the set of
students that are in 6.006?
And if it does, then I can
pull that student back.
And then associated
with that object
is a bunch of other information
that I'm not using to search--
so for instance,
your name, your--
I don't know-- your social
security number, your credit
card number, all the
other stuff that I
need to have a more
interesting profession.
So in any event, let's fill
in the details of our set
interface a little bit more.
So our set is a container.
It contains all of the
students in this classroom,
in some virtual sense at least.
And so to build up
our set, of course,
we need an operation that
takes some iterable object A
and builds a set out of it.
So in other words, I
have all the students
in this classroom represented
maybe in some other fashion.
And I have to insert
them all into my set.
I can also ask my set for
how much stuff is in it.
Personally, I would
call that size.
But length is cool, too.
And then of course, there
are a lot of different ways
that we can interact
with our set.
So for instance, we could say,
is this student taking 6.006?
So in set language, one
way to understand that
is to say that the key--
each person in this classroom
is associated with a key.
Does that key k exist in my set?
In which case, I'll
call this find function,
which will give me back the
item with key k or maybe null
or something if
it doesn't exist.
Maybe I can delete an object
from my set or insert it.
Notice that these are
dynamic operations,
meaning that they actually
edit what's inside of my set.
And then finally, there are all
kinds of different operations
that I might want to do to
interact with my set beyond
is this thing inside of it.
So for instance, so for
the student ID example,
probably finding the
minimum ID number in a class
isn't a terribly
exciting exercise.
But maybe I'm trying to
find the student who's
been at MIT the longest.
And so that would be a
reasonable heuristic.
I actually have no idea
whether MIT student IDs
are assigned linearly or not.
But in any event, I could find
the smallest key, the largest
key, and so on in my set.
And these are all
reasonable operations
to query, where
my object is just
a thing that stores a lot of
different entities inside it.
Now, this description here--
notice that I've labeled
this as a set interface.
This is not a set
data structure.
And the way to remember that
is that I haven't told you how
I've actually implemented this.
I haven't told you that I'm
going to behind the scenes
have an array of information,
and look inside of it,
and that's how I'm going to
implement find min or find max
with a for loop or whatever.
All I'm telling you is
that a set is a thing that
implements these operations.
And behind the scenes, my
computer does what it does.
Now, it might sound abstract.
But it's more or
less what you guys do
when you write code in Python.
I think in Python
what we're calling
a set is maybe a dictionary.
I'm a Matlab Coder.
I'm sorry.
I'm a numerical
analysis kind of guy.
But essentially, one
of the beautiful things
about coding in these high
level programming languages
is that they take care
of these ugly details.
And what you're
left with is just
the high level interfacing
with this object
that you need at
the end of the day.
So of course, in today's
lecture, now that we set out
our goal, which is to fill in--
if I wanted to write code
for a set, how could I do it?
Now, of course, our goal is to
give different data structures
that implement these,
and then understand them
in terms of their efficiency,
data storage, correctness,
all that good stuff.
So before we get into
all these ugly details,
let me pause for a second.
Are there any questions
about this basic interface?
You all should feel
free to stop me any time
because this is going to be
hella boring if you're not
getting the first slide or two.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain how [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN: That's a good question.
So the question
was, what exactly
is this insert operation doing?
That's why working
on the analogy
of the students in this
classroom is a reasonable one.
So I'm going to build up an
object, which is a student.
So in this lecture notes, I
think we've been consistent.
I caught one or two typos.
We're going to think of x
as the object that contains
all of the information.
And then associated
with that is one piece,
which is called the key.
That's where we're
going to use a letter k.
And that's like your student ID.
That's the thing I'm
going to use to search.
So what the Insert
operation does
that takes this
whole student object
x, which includes your ID, your
name, your phone number, all
that good stuff, and
inserts it into the set
with the understanding
that when I search my set,
I'm going to be
searching by key.
So when I want to
find a student,
I have to put in my ID number.
Does that makes sense?
Cool.
Any other questions?
That's great.
Fabulous.
OK.
So now, let's talk about how to
actually implement this thing.
And thankfully, we're already
equipped with at least a very
simple way that we can implement
a set based on what you've
already seen in your previous
programming classes or even
just in the last two lectures,
which is one way to understand
a set or to implement it
rather would be to just store
a giant array of objects
that are in my set.
I suppose continuing with the
theme of the last two lectures,
this is not a space
in memory, but rather
a metaphorical array,
a theoretical array.
But it doesn't really matter.
And so one way to
store my set would
be to just store a bunch of
x's in no particular order.
Does that make sense?
So I have a big piece of memory.
Every piece of
memory is associated
with a different
object in my set.
Obviously, this is
quite easy to build.
I just make a big array and
dump everything in there.
And the question is, is
this particularly efficient
or a useful way to
implement a set?
So for instance,
let's say that I
have a set of all the
students in this classroom.
There's some ridiculous
number of you guys.
So actually, asymptotic
efficiency maybe
actually matters a little bit.
And I want to query, does this
student exist in my class?
Is Erik Demaine taking 6.006?
The answer is no, I think.
Teaching, taking?
I don't know.
But in any event,
how do I implement it
if my set is unordered?
We'll think about
it for a second.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: It's actually an
interesting suggestion,
which is going to anticipate
what's happening later
in this lecture, which was
to sort the set and then
binary search.
But let's say that actually
I only have to do this once.
For some reason, I built up
a whole set of the people
in this classroom.
And I just want to know, is
Erik Demaine in this class?
So then that algorithm
would take n log n time
because I've got
to sort everybody.
And then I have to do
binary search, which
is maybe log n time.
But I claim that, if the
only thing I care about
is building up my entire
set and searching it once,
there's actually a
faster algorithm.
This is going to be needlessly
confusing because we're
going to see that this is really
not the right way to implement
it in about 38 seconds.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Yeah.
Just iterate from beginning
to this array and say,
is this guy Erik?
No.
Is this guy Erik?
Yes.
And then return it.
So in the worst case, how
long will that algorithm take?
Well, in the worst case
of really bad luck,
your instructor is all the
way at the end of the list.
So in this case, what
is that going to mean?
That means that I have to
walk along the entire array
before I find him.
So that algorithm
takes order n time.
And so your
colleague's intuition
that somehow this
is quite inefficient
is absolutely correct.
If I know that I'm
going to have to search
my array many, many times for
different people, then probably
it makes sense to do a little
bit of work ahead of time,
like sorting the list.
And then my query is
much more efficient.
But this is all just to say
that an unordered array is
a perfectly reasonable way to
implement this set interface.
And then searching that array
it will take linear time
every single time I search.
And of course, if
you go down your list
of all of the different
operations you might
want to do on a set, you'll see
that they all take linear time.
So for instance, how
do I build myself?
Well, I have to reserve
n slots in memory.
And at least
according to our model
of computation in this class,
that takes order n time.
Then I'm going to copy
everything into the set.
Similarly, if I want
to insert or delete,
what do I have to do?
Well, I have to reserve
memory, stick something
inside of there.
In the worst case, we saw
this amortize argument before,
if your set is allowed
to grow dynamically.
And finally, if I wanted
to find the minimum student
ID in my classroom,
the only algorithm
I can have if my list
of students isn't sorted
is to what?
Just iterate over every
single student in the class.
And if the guy
that I'm looking at
has a smaller ID than the
one that I found, replace it.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
So basically, everything you can
do in a set you can implement--
and I think all of
you guys are more than
qualified to implement--
as an unordered array.
It's just going to be slow.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Yeah, that's right.
So actually, I don't
know in this class.
I guess, the interface
and the way that we've
described it here is dynamic.
We can just keep
adding stuff to it.
In that case, remember
this amortized argument
from Erik's lecture
says that on average
that it will take order n time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: What was that?
JUSTIN: Oh, that's true.
That's an even better-- sorry.
Even if it weren't dynamic.
If I wanted to replace
an existing key--
like, for some reason, two
students had the same ID.
This is a terrible analogy.
I'm sorry.
But in any event, if
I wanted to replace
an object with a new one,
well, what would I have to do?
I'd have to search
for that object
first, and then replace it.
And that search is going to take
order n time from our argument
before.
Thank you.
OK.
So in some sense, we're done.
We've now implemented
the interface.
Life is good.
And of course, this
is the difference
between existence and actually
caring about the details
inside of this thing.
We've shown that one
can implement a set.
But it's not a
terribly efficient way
to do it by just storing a big,
hot mess, disorganized list
of numbers without any order.
So instead of
that, conveniently,
our colleague in
the front row here
has already suggested a
different data structure,
which is to store our set not
as just a disorganized array
in any arbitrary order, but
rather to keep the items
in our set organized by key.
So in other words, if I
have this array of all
of the students
in our classroom,
the very first
element in my array
is going to be the student
with the smallest ID number,
the second is the second
smallest number, all
the way to the end
of the array, which
is the student with
the biggest ID number.
Now, does that mean I
want to do arithmetic
on student ID numbers?
Absolutely not.
But it's just a way to
impose order on that list
so that I can search
it very quickly later.
OK.
So if I want to fill
in the set interface
and I have somehow a
sorted array of students--
so again, they're organized
by student ID number--
then my runtime starts to get
a little more interesting.
Yeah.
So now, insertion,
deletion they'd still
take the same amount of time.
But let's say that
I want to find
the student with the minimum ID
number, this find min function.
Well, how could I do
it in a sorted array?
Keyword is sorted here.
Where's the min
element of an array?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Yeah.
In fact, I can give a moderately
faster algorithm, which
is just look at the first one.
If I want the minimum element
of an array and the array
is in sorted order, I know
that's the first thing.
So that's order 1 time to
answer that kind of a question.
And similarly, if I want the
thing with the biggest ID
number, I look all
the way at the end.
Now, in 6.006--
MIT student class numbers
are super confusing to me.
In 6.0001, 6.042,
you guys already
I think learned
about binary search
and even may have
implemented it.
So what do we know?
If my array is sorted,
how long does it
take for me to search
for any given element?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Log n time.
JUSTIN: Log n time.
That's absolutely right because
I can cut my array in half.
If my key is bigger
or smaller, then I
look on the left or the right.
And so this is a much
more efficient means
of searching a set.
So in particular, 6.006
this year has 400 students.
Maybe next year, it has 4,000.
And eventually, it's
going to have billions.
Then what's going to happen?
Well, if I use my
unordered array
and I have a billion
students in this class,
what's going to happen?
Well, then it's going to take me
roughly a billion computations
to find any one
student in this course,
whereas log of a billion
is a heck of a lot faster.
On the other hand, I've
swept under the rug
here, which is how
do I actually get
a sorted array to begin with.
And what we're going to
see in today's lecture
is that that takes more
time than building if I just
have a disorganized list.
Building a disorganized
list is an easy thing to do.
You probably all do it at home
when you're cleaning house.
But actually, sorting
a list of numbers
requires a little bit more work.
And so this is a great
example where there's at least
a tiny amount of tradeoff.
Now, building my sorted
array to represent my set
is going to take a
little more computation.
We're going to see
it's n log n time.
But then once I've
done that step 0,
now a lot of these
other operations
that I typically
care about in a set,
like searching it
for a given key,
are going to go a lot
faster using binary search.
So this is our basic
motivator here.
And so now, we've seen the
setup interface and two
potential data structures.
And our goal for
the day is going
to be to fill in the
details of that second one.
And since you all have
already seen binary search,
you've probably also
already seen sorting.
But in any event,
today, we're going
to focus mostly on
the lower left square
here, on just how can I take
a disorganized list of objects
and put it into sorted order so
that I can search for it later.
So in other words, our big
problem for lecture today
is the second thing
here, this sorting.
Incidentally, in the
next couple of lectures,
we're going to see other
data sets-- or data
structures, rather.
Sorry, data sets.
I used to teach
machine learning class.
And we'll see that they have
different efficiency operations
that we can fill in this table.
So we're not done yet.
But this is one step forward.
OK.
So hopefully, I have
ad nauseum justified
why one might want
to sort things.
And indeed, there are a
couple of vocabulary words
that are worth noting.
So one, so remember that
your sorting algorithm
is pretty straightforward in
terms of how you specify it.
So in sorting, your input
is an array of n numbers.
I suppose actually
really that we
should think of them like keys.
It's not going to
matter a whole lot.
And our output--
I'm always very
concerned that if I
write on the board on the
back, I have to cover it up--
is going to be sorted array.
And we'll call this
guy B. We'll call
this one A. This classroom is
not optimized for short people.
So there's a lot of variations
on the basics sorting
problem and the different
algorithms that are out there.
Two vocabulary words are going
to highlight really quick--
one is if your sort
is destructive,
what that means is that rather
than reserving some new memory
for my sorted array B and then
putting a sorted version of A
into B, a destructive algorithm
is one that just overwrites A
with a sorted version of A.
Certainly the C++ interface
does this.
I assume the Python
one does, too.
I always forget this detail.
In addition to
destructive sorts,
some sorts are in place,
meaning that not only are
they destructive, but they
also don't use extra memory
in the process of sorting.
Really, you could imagine
a sorting algorithm
that has to reserve a bunch of
scratch space to do its work,
and then put it back into A.
For instance, the world's
dumbest destructive sort
might be to call
your non-destructive
and then copy it back
into A. But that would
require order n space to do.
So if my algorithm
additionally has
the property that it doesn't
reserve any extra space,
at least up to a constant,
then we call that in place.
OK.
So those are our basic
vocabulary words.
And they're ways to
understand the differences
between different
sorting algorithms.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Why do they end
up using extra O(1) space?
Oh yeah, sure.
Any time I just make
a temporary variable
like a loop counter,
that's going
to count toward that order 1.
But the important thing is that
the number of variables I need
doesn't scale in the
length of the list.
OK.
So I present to you
the beginning and end
of our sorting lecture, which
is the world's simplest sorting
algorithm.
I call it permutation sort.
I think it's very easy
to prove correctness
for this particular technique.
So in permutation
sort, what can I do?
Well, I know that if I have an
input that's a list of numbers,
there exists a permutation
of that list of numbers that
is sorted by definition
because a sort is
a permutation of
your original list.
So what's a very simple
sorting algorithm?
Well, list every
possible permutation,
and then just double check
which one's in the right order.
So there's two key pieces to
this particular technique,
if we want to analyze it.
I don't see a reason
to belabor it too much.
But one is that we have to
enumerate the permutations.
Now, if I have a
list of n numbers,
how many different permutations
of n numbers are there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: n factorial.
JUSTIN: n factorial.
So just by virtue of calling
this permutation's function,
I know that I incur at
least n factorial time.
It might be worse.
It might be that like actually
listing permutations takes
a lot of time for some
reason, like every permutation
itself takes order n time.
But at the very least,
each one of these things
looks like n factorial.
I warned you my
handwriting is terrible.
So that's what this omega thing
is doing, if I recall properly.
And then secondarily,
well, we've
got to check if that particular
permutation is sorted.
How are we going to do that?
There's a very easy way to
check if a list is sorted.
I'm going to do maybe for
i equals 1 to n minus 1.
Notice not a Python coder.
It's going to look different.
Then check, is Bi less
than or equal to Bi plus 1?
And so if this relationship
is true for every single i--
that's supposed to
be a question mark.
This was less than or equal to
with a question mark over it.
There's my special notation.
So if I get all the way to
the end of this for loop
and this is true everywhere,
then my list is sorted
and life is good.
So how long does
this algorithm take?
Well, it's staring
you right in the face
because you have
an algorithm, which
is looping from 1 to n minus 1.
So this step incurs order n
time because theta of n time
because it's got to go all the
way to the end of the list.
So when I put these things
together, permutation sort--
well, remember that this
check if sorted happens
for every single permutation.
So at the end of the
day, our algorithm
takes at least n
factorial times n time.
It's a great
example of something
that's even worse than
n factorial, which
somehow in my head is like
the worst possible algorithm.
So do you think that Python
implements permutation sort?
I certainly hope not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Right.
So the question was, why
is it omega and not big O?
Which is a fabulous
question in this course.
So here's the basic issue.
I haven't given you
an algorithm for how
to compute the set
of permutations
for a list of numbers.
I just called some magic
function that I made up.
But I know that that algorithm
takes at least n factorial time
in some sense.
Or if nothing else, the
list of permutations
is n factorial
big because that's
all the stuff has to compute.
So I haven't told you how
to solve this problem.
But I'm convinced that it's
at least this amount of time.
So remember that omega
means lower bound.
So when I put it all
together, in some sense--
OK, this isn't
satisfying in the sense
that I didn't give you precisely
the runtime of this algorithm.
But hopefully, I've convinced
you that it's super useless.
Yeah, OK.
Any other questions about that?
But great.
So if we go back to our
table for the set interface,
well, in some sense,
if we implemented
it using this goofy algorithm,
then the lower left entry
in our table would
be n factorial times
n, which wouldn't be so hot.
But notice that actually all
the rest of our operations
are now quite efficient.
I can use binary search.
I just obtained the
algorithm that--
rather, I obtained the sorted
array in a funny fashion.
OK.
So let's fill in some more
interesting algorithms.
As usual, I'm talking too much.
And I'm nervous about the time.
But we can skip one
of them if we need to.
So how many of us have
seen selection sort before?
I see your hand.
But we're going to
defer for a little bit.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: That's fabulous.
Why don't we defer to
the end of lecture?
And we'll do it then.
OK.
So the first algorithm that
we'll talk about for sorting,
which is somewhat
sensible, is something
called selection sort.
Selection sort is exactly
what it sounds like.
So let's say that we have a
list of-- whoops, my laptop
and the screen are not agreeing.
OK.
Let's say I have a
list of numbers--
8, 2, 4, 9, 3.
There's a message
that Jason I think
is sending me in
the course notes.
But I haven't figured it out.
But in any event, I want to
sort this list of numbers.
Here's a simple algorithm
for how to do it,
which is I can find the biggest
number in this whole list
and stick it at the end.
So in this case, what's
the biggest number
in this list everybody?
9.
Good.
See, this is why you go to MIT.
So I'm going to take that 9.
I find it.
And then swap it out with
the 3, which is at the end.
And now, what's my
inductive hypothesis?
Well, in some sense,
it's that everything
to the right of this little
red line that I've drawn here
is in sorted order, in this case
because there's only one thing.
So now, what am I going to do?
I'm going to look to the
left of the red line,
find the next biggest thing.
What's that?
Come on.
AUDIENCE: 8.
JUSTIN: There we go.
Yeah, wake up.
OK.
So right, the next
biggest one is the 8.
So we're going to swap it
with the 3, put it at the end,
and so on.
I think you guys could
all finish this off.
I suppose there should be one
last line here where everything
is green and we're happy.
But in some sense, we're pretty
sure that an array of one item
is in sorted order.
And so essentially, from a high
level, what does selection sort
do?
Well, it just kept choosing the
element which was the biggest
and swapping it into the
back and then iterating.
Now, in 6.006, we're going to
write selection sort in a way
that you might not
be familiar with.
In some sense, this is not
so hard to implement with two
for loops.
I think you guys could
all do this at home.
In fact, you may have already.
But in this class,
because we're concerned
with proving correctness,
proving efficiency,
all that good stuff,
we're going to write it
in kind of a funny way,
which is recursive.
Now, I can't emphasize strongly
enough how little you guys
should implement this at home.
This is mostly a theoretical
version of selection sort
rather than one that
you would actually
want to write in code
because there's obviously
a much better way to do it.
And you'll see that in
your recitation this week,
I believe.
But in terms of
analysis, there's
a nice, easy way
to write it down.
So we're going to take the
selection sort algorithm.
And we're going to divide
it into two chunks.
One of them is find me the
biggest thing in the first k
elements of my array.
I shouldn't use k
because that means key.
The first i elements
of my array.
And the next one is
to swap it into place
and then sort
everything to the left.
That's the two pieces here.
So let's write that down.
So what did I do?
Well, in some sense,
in step 1 here, I
found the biggest with index
less than or equal to i.
So I started at the end of the
list, and then moved backward.
And then step 2 was to
swap that into place.
Notice when I say
swap-- so for instance,
when I put the 8
there, well, I had
to do something with that 3.
So I just put it where
the 8 used to be.
And then finally,
well, am I done?
No, I just put the biggest
thing at the end of my array.
So now, I have to sort
from index 1 to i minus 1
because now I know that the
last guy is in sorted order.
I see you.
I'll turn it over to
you in just a sec.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: You can't
read the handwriting?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: This is index
less than or equal to i.
Great question.
I warned you.
It's going to be a problem.
So let's do step 1 first.
So I'm going to put
code on the board.
And then we're going
to fill in the details.
Erik is posting on Facebook.
I'm going to turn that
feature off on my watch later.
So right, let's implement
this helper function here.
This is something we're
going to call prefix max.
And this is going to
find me the biggest
element of array between
index 0 and index i inclusive,
I believe.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Well, here's an
interesting observation,
really a deep one, which is
that the biggest element from 0
to i--
that's an i, sorry.
There's two cases.
Either it's at index i,
meaning I have the first 10
elements of my right--
either it is element number
10 or what's the other case?
It ain't, Yeah?
In other words, it
has index less than i.
This is a tautology, rate?
Either the biggest thing is
at this index or it's not.
In which case, it has
to be to the left.
Does that makes sense?
So this gives us a
really simple algorithm
for finding the biggest element
in the array between index 0
and index i, which is what I've
shown you on the screen here.
I'd write it on the board.
But I am a slow writer
and already low on time.
And so essentially,
what did I implement?
Well, I found the biggest
element between index 0
and index i minus 1.
So let's say that
I have an array--
I forget the
sequence of numbers--
8, 3, 5, 7, 9.
That'll do it.
And so like I give a
pointer here, which is i.
And the very first
thing that I do
is I compute the biggest
number all the way to the left
of this stuff.
In this case, that is?
AUDIENCE: 8.
JUSTIN: 8.
There we go.
Now, I look at the very last
element of my array, which is--
9.
You're killing me today, guys.
And then what do I return?
Well, I want the biggest
one between 0 and index i.
So in this case, I return the 9.
Does that make sense?
So I know Jerry Cain
at Stanford likes
to talk about the recursive
leap of faith that happens.
Another term for
this is induction.
So we want to prove that
our algorithm works.
Well, what do we have to do?
We have to show that when
I call this function,
it gives me the max of
my array between index 0
and index i for all i.
So let's maybe do this inductive
proof a little bit carefully.
And then the rest, we'll
be sloppy about it.
So the base case is i equals 0.
Well, in this case, there's
only one element in my array.
So it's pretty clear
that it's the max.
And now, we have to do
our inductive step, which
means that if I call
prefix max with i minus 1,
I really do get the max
of my array between 0
and index i minus 1.
And then really, I can just
look at my very deep statement,
which is that either my object
is at the end of the array
or it's not.
And this is precisely
what we need
to justify the inductive step.
Essentially, there
are two cases.
Either the biggest element of
my arrays the last one or it's
not.
We already, by our
inductive hypothesis,
have argued that
our code can find
the biggest element between
index 0 and index i minus 1.
So as long as we take the max
of that and the very last guy,
we're in good shape.
So this is our very informal
proof of correctness.
OK.
So now, we have to justify
runtime for this algorithm.
And that's actually not
100% obvious from the way
I've written it here.
There's no for loop.
But what do I do?
Well, in some sense,
if my run time
is a function s,
well, for one thing,
if my array has
one element in it,
well, my run time might
be 7, might be 23.
But at the end of the day,
it only does one thing.
It just returns i.
So in other words,
it's theta of 1.
This isn't terribly insightful.
But what else do we know?
Well, when I call my function,
I call it recursively on
one smaller index.
And then I do a
constant amount of work.
So I know that s of n is
equal to s of n minus 1
plus theta of 1.
I do a little bit of extra
computation on top of that.
Can anybody guess what this
total runtime is going to be?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN: Yeah, order n.
So let's say that we hypothesize
that this takes n time.
You can see that because at
step n we call n minus 1,
we call it minus 2, and so
on, all the way down to 1.
If we want to prove this,
one of the ways that we--
I think, in theory, you guys
have learned in the past--
and you're going to
cover it in recitation--
is a technique
called substitution.
What we do is we're going to
look at this relationship.
And we're going to hypothesize
that we think s of n
maybe look something like
cn for some constant c that
doesn't depend on n.
Then all we have to
do is double check
that that relationship
is consistent
with our inductive
hypothesis, or rather
just as a recursive function.
And if it is, then
we're in good shape.
So in this case,
well, what do I know?
I've guessed that s
of n is theta of n.
In particular, if I plug into
this recursive relationship
here, on the left-hand
side, I'm going to get cn.
On the right-hand side, I'm
going to get c n minus 1
plus theta of 1.
We just have to make sure
that this is an OK equal sign.
So what can I do?
I can subtract cn
from both sides,
maybe put that 1 on
the other side here.
Then we get the c
equals big I of 1.
c is, of course, a constant.
So we're in good shape.
My undergrad
algorithms professor
told me never to write a victory
mark at the end of a proof.
You have to do a little square.
But he's not here.
So now, I see you.
But we're a little low on time.
So we'll save it
for the lecture.
OK.
So if we want to implement the
selection sort algorithm, well,
what do we do?
Well, we're going to think of
i as the index of that red line
that I was showing you before.
Everything beyond i
is already sorted.
So in selection sort, the
first thing I'm going to do
is find the max element
between 0 and i.
And then I'm going to
swap it into place.
So this is just a code
version of the technique
we've already talked about.
Hopefully, this makes sense.
So you find the biggest
element between 0 and index i.
That's what we're
going to call j here.
I swap that with
the one in index i.
That's step 2.
And then step 3 is I still
have to sort everything
to the left of index i and
that's that recursive call.
So if I want to
justify the runtime
of this particular
technique, well, now
let's call that t for time.
Well, what do I do?
Well, for one, I call selection
sort with index i minus 1.
So that incurs time
that looks like this.
But I also call that
prefix max function.
And how much time
does that take?
That takes order n time.
So at the end of the day,
I have some relationship
that looks like this.
Does that makes sense?
So by the way, notice that
this order n swallowed
up the order 1 computations that
I had to do to swap and so on.
So remember, there's this
nice relationship, which
you probably learned in your
combinatorics class, which
is that 1 plus 2 plus
dot, dot, dot plus n.
OK.
I can never remember
exactly the formula.
But I'm pretty sure that
it looks like n squared.
So based on that
and taking a look
at this recursive thing, which
is essentially doing exactly
that--
n plus n minus 1 plus
n minus 2, and so on--
I might hypothesize that
this thing is really
order n squared.
So if I'm going to
do that, then again
if I want to use the
same technique for proof,
I have to plug this
relationship in, and then double
check that is consistent.
So maybe I hypothesize that
t of n equals cn squared.
In which case, I
plug it in here.
I have cn squared equals
with a question mark over it
cn minus 1 squared plus
big O or even theta n here.
So if I expand
the square, notice
I'm going to get
c times n squared
plus a bunch of linear stuff.
This is really cn squared--
I should be careful with that--
minus 2 cn plus c
plus theta of n.
Notice that there's a cn squared
on both sides of this equation.
They go away.
And what I'm left with is
a nice, consistent formula
that theta of n
equals 2 cn minus c.
And indeed, this is
an order n expression.
So there's order
in the universe.
Life is good.
Yeah, this is the
substitution method.
And again, I think you'll cover
it more in your recitation.
So what have we done?
We have derived
the selection sort.
We've checked that it
runs in n squared time.
And by this nice,
inductive strategy,
we know that it's correct.
So life is pretty good.
Unfortunately, I promised
for you guys on the slides
that sorting really
takes n log n time.
And this is an order
n squared algorithm.
So we're not quite done yet.
I'm way over time.
So we're going to skip a
different algorithm, which
is called insertion sort,
also runs on n time.
Essentially, insertion sort
runs in the reverse order.
I'm going to sort
everything to the left,
and then insert a new object,
whereas, in selection, I'm
going to choose
the biggest object
and then sort
everything to the left.
But I'll let you guys
piece through that at home.
It's essentially
the same argument.
And instead, we should
jump to an algorithm
that actually matters, which
is something called merge sort.
How many of us have
encountered merge sort before?
Fabulous.
Good.
So then I'm done.
So let's say that I have a list.
Now, I'm sending a
message back to Jason.
I made this one up last night.
So I have 7, 1,
5, 6, 2, 4, 9, 3.
This is not in sorted order.
But I can make a very
deep observation,
which is that every number
by itself is in sorted order
if I think of it as
an array of length 1.
It's really deep, like
deep learning deep.
So now, what can I do?
Well, I could take every pair of
numbers, draw a little red box.
Well, now, they're
not in sorted order
any more inside
of the red boxes.
So I'm going to sort
inside of every box.
In this case, it's
not too exciting
because it's just pairs.
And now, they're in sorted order
because they said they were.
Now, I'm going to keep
doubling the size of my boxes.
So now, let's say I
have box of length 4.
What do I know about the
left and right-hand sides
of the dotted lines here?
On the two sides of
the dotted lines,
the array is in sorted order.
There's a 1 and then a 7.
Those are in sorted
order, 5 and a 6.
That's because, in the previous
step, I sorted every pair.
So when I merge these
two sides together,
I have an additional useful
piece of information,
namely that the two
sides of the dotted line
are already in sorted order.
That's going to be our
basic inductive step here.
So in this case, I
merge the two sides.
I get 1, 5, 6, 7,
and 2, 3, 4, 9.
Then finally, I put these
two things together.
And I have to sort these two.
I have to merge these
two sorted lists.
But they're in sorted order.
And that's going to give me a
big advantage because-- oops,
I lost my chalk.
I suppose I've got space
on this board here.
Oh no.
So if I want to merge 1,
5, 6, 7 and 2, 3, 4, 9,
there's a nice, clever
technique that we
can do that's going to
take just linear time.
Jason tells me it's the
two finger algorithm.
I think that's a
cute analogy here.
So here are my two fingers.
They're going to point
at the end of the list.
And I'm going to construct
the merged array backwards.
So how many elements are
in my merged array, if I'm
merging two things of length 4?
I don't ask you
guys hard questions.
It's 8, yeah?
4 plus 4.
8, yeah?
So what do I know?
I know that my merge array--
5, 6, 7-- has eight elements.
And now, I'm going to have two
fingers at the end of my array.
Which one should I put at
the end of the merged guy?
The 7 of the 9?
AUDIENCE: The 9
JUSTIN: The 9.
Right, thank you.
So now, I can move my
lower finger to the left
because I've already added that.
Notice that I never need to
look to the left of where
my finger is because they're
already in sorted order.
Now what should I
add, the 4 or the 7?
AUDIENCE: 7.
JUSTIN: The 7.
And so on, dot, dot, dot, yeah?
So that's going to be the
basic idea of the merge sort.
I'm going to take
two sorted lists.
And I'm going to make a
new sorted list, which
is twice as long,
by using two fingers
and moving from
the and backward.
So that's the basic
intuition here.
Indeed, there's our sorted list.
It's stressing me out
that there's no eight.
I need the power of 2.
So I think merge sort,
we're going to present it
in a backward way
from the previous one,
where I'm going to give you
the high level algorithm.
And then actually, the
headache is that merging step,
which I have four minutes for.
And I apologize for it.
So what does the merger sort do?
Well, it computes
an index c, which
is the middle of my array.
And it's going to make a
recursive call which is sort
the left, which is everything
between index A and index C.
And then sort everything on
the right, which is everything
from index C to index B.
I know this is confusing
because usually letters
appear in order.
But C, if you think of
as standing for center,
then it makes sense like.
Here's my array.
I'm going to choose an
index right in the middle.
I've done myself a disservice
by not using a power of 2.
But that's OK.
I'm going to say sort everything
to the left of the dotted line
first.
Sort everything to the right
of the dotted line second.
Now, I have two sorted
lists on the two
sides of the dotted line.
And then I'm going to use my two
fingers to put them together.
So that's what this
is implementing here.
See, there's two
recursive calls--
sort from A to C, and then
sort from C to B. Oops,
I didn't actually label this.
So this is A, C, B. And
then I've got to call merge.
Now, our implementation
of merge--
well, we can also do this
in a recursive fashion.
But personally, I find
this a little complicated.
I'm going to admit.
But here's the basic idea
here, which I'm now rushing.
So I'm going to think of
my upper finger as finger i
and my lower finger as finger j.
Does that makes sense?
So I have two sorted lists.
So maybe like that.
I don't know, 1, 3, 5, 7.
And then I have a
second sorted list here,
which is maybe 2, 4,
6, 72, as one does.
Then I'm going to have one
pointer like this, which is i,
and a pointer down
here, which is j.
And my goal is to
construct an array A
with a bunch of elements in it.
And the way that I'm
going to do it is I'm
going to use exactly the same
kind of recursive argument,
that I can either have
the biggest element of my
be the last element
of the first guy
or be the last element
of the second one.
So here's going to be
our recursive call.
And in addition to that,
for convenience, we'll
have a third index, which is B,
which is pointing to this thing
inside of my sorted array that
I'm currently processing Yeah?
It's going to start
at A, go to B.
Incidentally, I
see a lot of people
taking photos of the slides.
These are just copy
pasted from the notes.
OK.
So in this case, what should
I put in B for my two arrays?
I have 1, 3, 5, 7; 2, 4, 6, 72.
72, yeah?
Great.
So now, what am I going to do?
I'm just going to call
the merge function.
But I'm going to decrement
B because now I'm
happy with that last element.
And in addition to that,
I'm going to decrement j
because I already used it up.
And so that's our
recursive call here.
It's saying, if j is
less than or equal to 0--
so in other words,
I have an element
to use in one of the
lists of the other.
And maybe the left one is
bigger than the right one.
That's our first case.
That does not apply
in this example here.
Well, then I should
make the last element
of a from the first
list and then recurse
with one fewer element
i, and similarly
the reverse case for j.
So if we do our runtime
in two minutes or less--
bare with me guys--
well, what is this merge
function going to do?
Well, in some sense,
there's two branches.
There's an if statement
with two pieces.
But both of those
pieces call merge
with one fewer piece in it.
So in some sense, we have s
of n equals s of n minus 1
plus theta of 1,
which we already
know from our previous
proof means that s of n
is equal to theta of n.
So in other words, it
takes linear time to merge.
It makes sense intuitively
because essentially you're
touching every one
of these things
once with your two fingers.
And now, probably
the hardest part
of the lecture, which
I left zero time for,
is deriving the runtime for the
actual merge sort algorithm.
And what does that look like?
Well, that one's a little bit
trickier because, of course,
I call the merge sort
algorithm twice, each time
on a list that's half the size.
In this class, we're going to
assume that our list is always
a power of 2 in its length.
Otherwise, this analysis
is a itty bitty bit more
of a headache.
So first of all,
how long does it
take to sort an
array of length 1?
I am not going to
ask hard questions.
Everybody?
Yeah, it's just 1, right?
Because there's nothing to do.
An array of length 1 has
one element and it's sorted.
It's also the biggest element
and the smallest element.
And now, what does
our algorithm do?
Well, it makes two
recursive calls
on lists that are
half the length.
And then it calls
that merge function.
And we know that the merge
function takes theta of n time.
Does that make sense?
So one thing we might do,
because we have some intuition
from your 6042
course, is that we
think that this thing is order
n log n because it makes the two
recursive calls.
And then it puts them together.
And let's double check that
that's true really quick using
the substitution method.
So in particular, on
the left-hand side
here, maybe I have cn log n.
Now, I have 2 c.
Well, I have to put an n over
2 log n over 2 plus theta of n.
And I want to double check that
this expression is consistent.
I've got about a
foot to do it in.
So remember-- let's see.
If we use our favorite
identities from high school
class that you probably
forgot, remember
that log of 2 things
divided by each other
is the difference of the logs.
So this is really 2.
OK.
2 divided by 2 is 1.
So this is c times n times log
n minus log of 2 plus theta n.
I'm already out of time.
But notice that there's a c n
log n on the right-hand side.
There's a c n log n
on the left-hand side.
So those two things go away.
And what am I going
to be left with?
I'm going to be left with
theta of n equals cn log of 2.
Notice that c and log
2 are both constants.
We have a theta event
on the left-hand side.
So there's order
in the universe.
And we've derived our runtime.
So I know I rest a little
bit through merge sort.
I'm sure that Erik and Jason
can review this a little bit
next time.
But with that,
we'll see you, what?
Thursday and Friday.
And it's been a pleasure
to talk to you all.